what's up you beautiful listeners hope
you're having a fantastic monday welcome
back to the evan and katelyn podcast
buckle up hit that like button
let's just jump into it
okay that was good it also was relevant
yeah for what we're doing today so um if
for those of you guys who don't know
philip defranco he's been on youtube for
a long time he has a new show but he
also has
um uh and in that news show that's the
intro that he uses but he also has a
podcast
and recently he's been playing this very
interesting
card game it's a set from the skin deep
not sponsored or anything but we have a
few different sets and they have
very personal and deep questions on them
and we haven't looked at
any of these we have not and there's a
bunch of different sets we just bought
all of them there's
the co-worker set which is relevant to
us
yeah as co-workers the dating edition we
did date
yeah the couple's edition for like the
long term
and the friend so like we fit we we have
experience in all of those categories
yeah i'm really excited to to hop into
this which one do you want to start with
first
i don't know let's just let's just
choose a long-term one let's just like
just go straight to like probably the
deepest okay okay okay okay wait
let me let me just back up a second
these questions
even like when he busts out the friends
ones or the co-workers ones
they're pretty deep are you reading the
how to play oh okay okay
isn't the how to play you just take
turns answering questions
i think so okay we just draw the card
and we answer the question right
so i we can decide if we want to both
answer the question or if we want to um
i think let's both
answer it if we want to let's just let's
play it by you play it by yourself
okay how to play sit facing one another
with a foot distance between you that's
very specific also friendly and that's
uh this is the friends edition one foot
apart
that's like like wait like your face is
one foot apart that means
if you're facing each other you're like
in that person's lap
now take 30 seconds to relax and look at
one another
you probably won't take the full 30
seconds no that would be really bad for
the podcast
you're closer than a flight i've invaded
your personal space
person one begins by asking a question
and they answer it continue back and
forth until you're through all the
questions okay
yeah interesting instructions okay i'll
ask the first question
okay what is it about me that makes you
think i understand you
hmm there's a
there's a lot of this is interesting
because it's like
i just know that you understand me so
i'm trying to put it into words about
like the specific reasons why
one is because we talk a lot honestly so
like we're over communicating all the
time
about everything and i say over
communicating not
like in about i call it over
communicating because it's i think more
than most people
talk and analyze things but it's normal
for us um
but yeah we just we give each other
the time to communicate our thoughts and
feelings so i feel understood by you
and it's also interesting thinking back
like going back in time says the friends
edition we could even like kind of oh i
thought you said couples edition oh no
this this is the friends edition
okay that i started with just because
like you know to ramp it up no i'm just
i'm
uh just saying because you you had said
long term earlier
i swapped i swapped right right i'm just
trying to fill in the people
so i think it's interesting because
because we can think about this question
like even back when we were just friends
for four years
what is it about music five years that
makes you think that i understand you
we had a really good understanding right
away
like we we worked great together in
english class we did
you know what's funny is we made a video
together oh
guys don't even ask we're not gonna
share it i don't even know i don't even
know where to find it it's so cringe
wasn't it like it was it was me you and
there's one other girl in our group and
didn't we
it was all about like freshmen fighting
on campus yeah it was about
communication skills
yeah but it was like one of us was your
girlfriend
and one of us was like jealous i don't
know i don't remember it
it was so dumb i just remember like
being in that girl's closet
and i was like i don't even know this
girl
but it's interesting because we had a
really good understanding of each other
right from the beginning we would like
go to each other for advice and we would
um we'd have a lot of meals together a
lot of meals together yes
we you know what we we were dance
partners together
and even you need a lot of non-verbal
communication you need a lot of
non-verbal communication for that it's
all about like
good lead and good following and stuff
and we had that
right from the beginning that's very
interesting it's very interesting and we
still have good non-verbal communication
skills
we do even better yeah years of practice
we have that very much that like if
we're in a group of people
we can like look at each other yeah and
know what the other one
knows the other one's like okay i'm
ready to go home now
can you help me escape yeah that's great
so are you opening another pack i'm
opening another pack just to like stay
ahead of things i'm just trying to like
uh
say it because people can't see what
you're doing and like
at first i thought we were doing the
relationship so i was answering more in
terms of like our relationship then
than the friends friends so now you're
opening the co-workers edition
what i was thinking you can you can draw
from either do you want to draw from the
friends of the co-workers
i think we should stick to just friends
oh
would you rather we'd be just co-workers
no i was saying like if if we're gonna
do this for more than one podcast
wouldn't it make more sense to be
like would it make more sense to stick
to categories or do you think it doesn't
really matter i don't think it really
matters i think it's fun to explore
around
it's it's interesting because also like
then like we can we can do a little bit
of friends a little bit of co-workers a
little bit of dating a little bit
long-term
later this is just us exploring this
dangerous and personal card game
okay cool i will open the co-workers
edition
do we get along the best ooh
we get along the best when we're not
under time pressure
yes i think that's like that's the only
thing
that complicates us getting along
because we always get along but the only
thing that like throws us
off is when we're in a rush and we're
not doing the things that we normally do
like communicating planning and you know
all of that stuff
so time pressure is the only thing that
like i think throws us off
yeah yeah i would agree with that yeah
much more dad if you're gonna
keep our discard piles separate so we
know like what they go with like
actually maybe even put them underneath
you know i think that we'll just turn
them over but we'll put them back in
upside down once we're done
okay yeah but we'll have different
discard piles okay i'm just
worried about the logistics of the put
in the caps no because they're they're
different colors
oh you're right they're they're called
we'll be fine
if you could have a skill set or trait
of mine what would it be and why
3d modeling oh and like not just 3d
modeling but the
type of brain that can picture
3d objects and their relationship
together
i think it's one of those things that
really just the the more you 3d model
the more you think in 3d
yeah kind of like i'm sure you think in
edits
i do think in edits and i also just a
more
like one-to-one comparison is i think in
illustrator
yeah like in 2d i think in like 2d
planes yeah
yeah but i think just like because i did
it for so many years
i i can kind of like picture the like
extrusions and rotations and chamfers
and all of that all
throughout it's also but it it's
partially that but it's also like
my whole life well no i was gonna say
it's partially the like
you know i learn i know i could just go
in and learn fusion
and i'm sure that learning fusion would
help with this other thing i'm about to
mention but part of it is just like
your ability to
picture how 3d objects will fit together
in your head you know a lot of times
when we're sketching ideas
like i have to ask you so many times i'm
like is this the front view is this the
top view
how big is that what is this part you
know and like
it just takes my brain a little bit
longer to process what your brain is
seeing
yeah i think i think that's one of those
things that like i'm not always a
subscriber of the like
idea of do how many hours like 10 000
hours
and 10 000 hours or whatever and then
like you'll become
a master at that or whatever i don't
think i'm a master at all but i think
it's one of those things that like
yeah there's no way to do it there's no
way to get that
unless you like put in those i know
thousands of hours
which i probably have by now which is
crazy i'm not sure if it's ten thousand
hours but it's a lot of hours
um i wanna actually um ask answer the
same thing for you
okay um one thing that i wish that i
could take from you
in terms of like skills and everything
skill set or traits
i think the trait is like
because i i get us into things but you
get us through them
you have like the gumption and
determination
and like steadfastness
to like get us through things so i think
that's really cool thank you yeah oh
yeah and i guess i answered more of the
skill set part than the trait
it's interesting you say that because if
i was gonna pick the trait
it would kind of be like your side of
that equation
which is like i am often more fearful
about starting new things and i get a
lot of stress like when we
sign up for something new and i'm like
oh god what do we get ourselves into can
we even do this
and i don't feel good about it until
like we're part way through it and i
know we can do it
it's interesting i wonder if those two
are like somewhat incompatible because
you think
of the entire journey all in its
entirety
and all that and that's like the
gumption and you knowing that you're
going to follow through with
it and i just like think of the first
step
and that's why i just jump into things
so
so maybe maybe they're they're a little
bit incompatible which is why you need
two people
so that's a good point good co-worker
skills good job
okay so should we move back to friends i
want to do another friend
okay i like i like jumping back and
forth
oh i like this when did you realize that
you could trust me
um because that's like a time question
yeah
well i think there's lots of little
moments
and most of them happened when we were
friends like before
we were in a relationship um
just like this is a very very shallow
example but it's literally like one of
our first interactions but like you
helped me with my computer
when we were new on campus and i had a
mac and like there weren't good
instructions for how to get your mac set
up on the network and i didn't know how
to do it
um and you're just i know you're very
like welcoming
and confident and you were just like oh
yeah i got that and i was like
okay thank you
um but that so that would probably be
like literally the first example
but again a very shallow one i think the
others are it kind of goes back to
our frequent talks during our frequent
classes about life and relationships
yeah well we talked a lot about like
relationships yeah relationships are
confusing
at least they were especially confusing
before i started dating you
yeah and then they got like very very
easy very easy
i was always wondering like how do you
know when you found the one and how
and and i you know everyone's journey is
different
you know every person is different and
every relationship is different but for
for me at least i was like when i knew i
knew and that was it was very easy
and i always wondered how i'd know and
then i knew how that was
anyways but like before i started dating
you we had a lot of concerns and
questions about
life and relationships yeah we would
often go to each other
for like advice on our current
relationships
like is this normal yeah because like
because interestingly it's like you know
i had
you know i had female friends and male
friends and my female friends i would
talk to about it but like my male
friends i didn't really feel comfortable
talking to them about it and so it was
helpful for me to get like a guy's
perspective and you were my only
guy friend that i like trusted to talk
about that stuff with
yeah that's crazy yeah it's crazy to
think back upon those times
weird let's go to dating speaking of
dating
let's move to the dating pack okay my
turn okay
okay
what would your ex say they taught you
i'm not sure what they would say but
i'll say something
my ex taught me that you really
you really have to communicate and
like not i don't know i don't want to be
critical
um
i i i think i have a way to put it but i
don't have to answer for you
because we've talked so well yeah we we
we've talked
all about x's and everything i think i
think
like one really valuable lesson from
the relationship the long-term
relationship you're in before me
is that you know
someone might think that
they're uh you know you know when you
like go through a change or change
something about yourself
um you know you can change for yourself
or you can change for other people and
it's kind of hard
sometimes to know who you're changing
for
um and i think what that person taught
you is if you're not
changing for the right reasons or if you
are projecting that you're
one type of person when you're actually
the old type of person
so it's all kind of vague but like it's
it
you can't keep that up forever can't
keep that forever yeah and so it's like
better just to
be yourself and be very aware of like if
you are
trying to change something about
yourself what are the reasons for that
yeah
i i'd say what would your ex say they
taught you to
to ask more questions at the beginning
of the relationship
to summarize it that way and to like
really get into
like deep questions right at the
beginning
because both of us are like long-term
dating people generally and like we we
we we're looking for long-term
relationships and everything and and i
think that when you are looking for that
long-term relationship
if you are like dancing around issues
and trying to be someone else
for one reason or another then
it's good to let the other person know
about that yeah
and i think there's no point continuing
if there's some major red flags that
could have been cleared up in the very
beginning
yeah and who knows if they're red flags
or not until you bring them out into the
open and talk about them you know
and i think that like that does show up
in our relationship
when before we even start dating before
we even told each other did we tell each
other that we liked each other before
the talk
okay it was the same talk all right so
we told each other that we liked each
other and then we had the full talk of
like
and i'm not saying that this is the way
to do things we i feel like we could
only do this because we
had already been friends for a really
long time and already talked about a lot
of deep things yeah
it'd be it'd be kind of weird to like
not like
meet someone and then say like let's
talk about all these deep things i don't
know
it might work it might not work on your
personality depends on your
personalities but
but like getting all that out and open
in the beginning
i think that was something that yeah i
learned
yeah okay do you want to ask see this is
why it's like a
deeply personal and sometimes dangerous
card game yeah
it's especially dangerous if you haven't
talked about all these things
could you imagine maybe people should
play this card game together
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah david go
through it start start
with the friends and then maybe go to
the dating yeah or just go straight to
the dating
yeah um
oh this is interesting i'm very
interested in these questions
what are you are you healing in you
what are you healing in you so it's like
are there anything
is there anything right now that you're
still healing from
i mean i would say
one thing this is more like
this is kind of like it's
work but work is very personal to us
because it's like our whole lives but i
i think there's a long time
uh and we talked about this a little bit
with our like imposter syndrome
episode and stuff um there's a
long time where like
i i felt like our channel was
on the right path but not quite there
and i felt like i didn't really
fit into it and i wasn't sure like am i
contributing enough like
do i am i good enough at making things
to be part of a maker channel when i'm
kind of
new to this and i i think like
what we've done over time is adjust the
channel
and now i feel like it is a more
accurate representation
of like who i am and my skill set i
don't
have as much fear that i'm like coming
off as pretending that i'm something i'm
not
um i feel like that's not a very
deep answer for a potentially very deep
card
yeah well and you know we're we're we're
in the lucky place where
we've we've kind of gotten past a lot of
things in our life
yeah to get here and and you know we're
no longer like healing
from from that much i mean like
this is also you know like there are
probably other things i could
bring up but because this is a podcast
not a private game we're playing just
with each other there are some things
that maybe i won't bring up
oh yeah yeah that's true it's true yeah
where oh wait do you wanna oh yeah
i'm picking and choosing
okay if oh this is an interesting
like wording if i had no fear whatsoever
what do you think is the first thing i
would do
ooh if you had no fear whatsoever what
is the first thing
yeah so it's like you assuming things
about me oh if i had no fear whatsoever
what do you think is the first thing i'd
do
pause our youtube career and go travel
just being realistic taking away well i
guess i wouldn't have fear of covet
oh yeah oh yeah okay yeah you know
excuse me excusing the current worldwide
pandemic
that that'd be my answer how does that
stack up
it's interesting because like i didn't
really i was trying to figure out my
answer
in my head and i do think that generally
it would be to be less afraid of just
like taking a month off or something
you know what i mean because we did we
that's the biggest fear in our life
right now in a way yeah it's like losing
momentum on the channel we
we're at a good place we're at a really
good place we don't want to hurt it
yeah i like what our life is right now
and i don't want to
hurt it yeah yeah yeah it's interesting
all right now we're moving into the long
term
the long-term couples edition okay this
is this is an interesting one
what do you think you still don't
understand about me
what do i still not understand about you
um i'll try to think of the same
yeah cause i'm curious like what your
answer like what do you feel
that i don't understand about you it's
hard because we have talked about
so much like like we'll we'll go for
like walks and
and everything and we'll just like talk
about whatever comes into our minds
i can i can answer something that like
took me longer than most things to
understand about
you and it's like it's kind of a
weird somewhat like might sound i don't
know silly or like petty example of
something
but it's something that like uh
when we i it wasn't from when we first
started dating it was kind of like
when earbuds became a thing wireless
earbuds became a thing
i know what it is so evan is someone who
like
almost always has an audio book
or like a podcast like you know i i
wasn't a lot of podcasts too but you
have like that and audiobook so there's
like always
something and i i used to
like i wouldn't always know when he had
his earbuds in
and so i would like say something to him
and you wouldn't respond and i get
really frustrated because i'm like
is he is he just ignoring me like
hello hello and then even once
you know i started realizing like
because it's you know i would realize
shortly after that you have an earbud in
but i would still get kind of annoyed
sometimes because we'd be like
doing something and then there would be
like a pause in the conversation yeah
and then you're like oh five minute
break i'll listen to my hair but like i
wouldn't have an earbud
like i wouldn't have a thing and like i
wouldn't know and then i'd say something
happening
but i think like i think things have
equalized some yeah i think i think the
thing is i
adjusted so i know like if we are doing
something long term together like uh
like if we're driving somewhere or we're
both like
working on some monotonous task in the
workshop
like i've learned that if
like i have my earbud on too and then
like if
if there's like a you know a break like
where sometimes we're talking and then
there'll be like a little break
and i can kind of tell more now when you
go into like
listening mode so then like i'll go into
listening mode for a little bit and then
we're better about like pausing to talk
and both of us being understanding like
about the other one having
something in their ear and that it's not
that like they don't want to
hang out or chat with you because i i
think i used to take it like well i
don't
i don't have my earbud in to like play
and meet as soon as there's like a lull
in conversation i think i used to take
it like am i boring
yeah you're not really am i boring but
like i don't know
i think i didn't really three things
because one
when you brought up that concern and you
explained your feelings to me
like we try to do a lot i
i think that to a certain degree i i did
become more understanding of it i tried
to listen to it
um when i had longer chunks yeah more
like like instead of just like
like five minutes here and there like
more constantly i tried to like
know when i'd have a longer period of
time and like
concentrate it in those sections or like
sometimes you'd give me a heads up
yeah another thing is you started like
saying like hey evan
and then you'd wait for me to like you'd
give me the heads up then you'd
you'd like wait for me to like look over
and everything and then would chat so
then that way
you don't feel like you're being ignored
yeah i'm not having to like repeat
i think the biggest thing is when you
started listening to audio books
too i don't know sorry a podcast also
i think that was part of it but for a
long time
i listened to them i mean i didn't i
didn't really get ear buds till we got
our like i didn't find anything
until we got our raycon it's not
sponsored i don't know why it knocked
out wood
i think the biggest thing is like yeah
like you saying like hey evan and then
mm-hmm so it's like we just like learned
how to yeah
communicate with that barry but i think
it took me a while to understand that
like
like your
brain especially like when you get into
those long-term
tasks like you really need that other
thing going on and so it's not that like
us being out there together is it's not
that it was like oh you didn't want to
chat with me
it was just like you assumed that there
would probably be like a lull in the
conversation and when you're doing this
by yourself you usually have your earbud
on so you have it out there just in case
you know what i mean and it's a habit
that i kind of got into
while i was working for years like
because when when you're doing 3d
modeling
you're not using words you know you're
using like dimensions
and and all of that stuff and there's a
lot of there's
some chunk of my work where like i knew
i'm gonna get so bored if i don't have
something else on so that was like a
solution i developed for myself and i
kind of got used to it and
and then when we started working
together yeah and
and just in in our personal life when i
was also working
so yeah what do you still that was nice
too yeah what do you still what do you
think you still don't well
yeah i kind of twisted it because i said
like one thing that i didn't that took
me a while
to get i think that for me
and then just to reiterate the question
it's what do you think you still don't
understand about me i think i i i can't
like i i'm very we're very lucky that we
don't have really any good answers for
this because we're at a good
understanding place but i think
like you said one thing that took me a
while to understand
was like
how caitlyn approaches being right and
and like
how how best to have like
i'm sorry for the way that i am no no i
love you
i accept all of you and this is
something that i've learned
you know and it wasn't that difficult
but it did take me a while
because often times when we would
discuss something that we weren't
fully on the same page about or caitlyn
had very strong feelings about
she would like she has kind of this way
that she talks in this way that she goes
about
like making arguments because kaitlyn is
very organized
and she keeps track of a lot in her head
and
she has them all lined up in a row
whenever like
a discussion needs to happen so should
kind of go through them all like make a
lot of points and you'd have a lot to
say
and i'm kind of like la la la let me
talk about my feelings and let me like
figure things out as i go and everything
and you know
there's a there's a discrepancy there
that isn't bad
but there is a difference in a way in
how we go about
um making points and everything and
like for the longest time like for some
reason
based on like my own and past and life
and
everything how caitlyn would go about
like making these points
i interpreted as her being upset with me
and that's not
what it was but like if i
personally took her style of
discussion as her being upset then i
would become upset which would make her
upset
in real life and so that she wasn't
upset but now she is upset
you know so it's like that was like
something that took us a little bit to
figure out
yeah and i'm not sure if i'm describing
it the best i'll be interested to get
your your
take on that too yeah it's interesting
because it's not really like i've
i've known that i am a right fighter
i was going to use networks sometimes
when i think that i'm right um
but yeah but it is hard to sway your
opinion
we have gotten there yeah yeah i think
you're one of the few people
no no no i mean this way my opinion but
it's it's usually when it comes it's
like depends on what the thing is
yeah i have a very like like
if it's something about the principle of
the thing you know
if it's like oh what's better this
option or this option you know you could
sway my opinion but if it's like a right
or wrong
kind of principle but uh so so anyways
yeah so
i've always known i'm like a right
friday or especially if i'm fighting for
like
like the principle of the thing but i
think the thing that i didn't realize
before we started dating is that like
the
way that i like the the way my
voice gets when i'm in that mode
because i always saw it as my like
almost more like i'm like presenting my
facts to you
yeah like i'm presenting my points or
i'm presenting
kind of like you're at a business
meeting and you're making a presence
yeah it's like my like presentation mode
yeah um but from the outside it comes
off as a
kind of like aggressive argumentative
mode
and there would be times where you're
like are you
angry at me and i i literally wouldn't
be angry
but like but my tone of voice
would would read as angry
even if like i or or like um frustrated
or something
and that's on but like maybe i'm
sensitive towards that maybe
or something yeah but it was just like
me being like
passionately feeling something but not
with like
anger behind it just like feeling very
strongly about a thing
yeah and i think i think that that was
the thing that took me a little bit to
figure out
in general yeah but now we just like ask
each other
yeah we're having doubts yeah we haven't
we haven't had any like issues around
that in a long time
no it's been a long time yeah which one
do you want to do next
um these all have been interesting
honestly co-workers we haven't done a
co-worker
let's do co-workers who asked last
i don't know we both kind of answer so
do you think we have an unspoken value
oh no what do you think is an unspoken
value we have in our organization
wholesomeness yeah but what's unspoken
because we actually have spoken about
wholesomeness okay unspoken value
all right i'll i'll add something that
we haven't like clarified in a long time
and i think that this is something we
have touched upon on the podcast on how
to start
a uh uh youtube channel
one unspoken value that we have in our
organization i think between us
is our clear priority for us to maintain
happiness internally and i think that
like
you know there's a lot of external
things that we project like we want to
be fairly family friendly we want to be
fairly wholesome we want to be uplifting
and positive
and all of these things but i think
internally it's something that we don't
say too much that like
the reason the whole reason why we
started this company in a way is to be
together and have
and be be happier and everything and
also
to be able to make content
that where we are happy and where we are
spreading positivity
we need to be happy ourselves and we
also don't want to burn out and like
have this be a
a short fuse of a adventure
and everything so it's like we want to
like
like keep that a high priority
in in a way yeah which is why like
like i know for example around the
beginning of this year
we changed from doing three videos a
month to two videos a month
and the channel could grow a lot faster
if we did three
or go in back to four which we used to
do a long time ago or with a podcast
why we moved to every other week and
that has been weekly
nice yeah and it's all because like
if we get too burnt out if we get too
stressed out uh
then we're not going to be happy and so
you know it that's even though this is
the co-worker
card and it's more about business our
our life and our business are basically
the same thing
they're very meshed yeah
or when people are like i wish you guys
would spend less time on the gaming
channel and more time making things
we're like too bad gaming channel is a
stress reliever
and like it makes us happy yeah
and like we wouldn't be able to make as
good videos if we
weren't happy and and the gaming music
is happy and also
you know the the whole gaming channel
has made us better about
improv and talking and interacting with
the audience and and it's made our
main channel videos better too i think
yeah we're a lot better at winging
intros remember how long intros you see
so we can spend a whole day on an intro
so long
you want to do one from the friends yeah
in what ways do you feel like we've
grown apart
oh that's one that doesn't really like
make sense here
yeah that's why i was confused about why
you're like do it
oh you know let's try to like let's try
to
like oh this is this is kind of strange
but like as friends like what do you do
as friends you go out to movies
you like you know hang out with other
friends and go on adventures and stuff
like that most of
like your time as friends is doing
friend stuff
you know and we are really good friends
you're my best friend and i love you and
you're my wife and all these other
things but it's like
we haven't made too much time in our
life
for friendship activities we haven't
gone on like vacations or gone to the
movies or
whatever you know we we still watch tv
every now and then
for like a short period of time every
day video games
oh play video games together you're
right no that that's true though i mean
again uh coveted stuff aside because you
know no one's
doing that i do think when we um it's
not really when we started the channel
a part of it is also like the job you
had before starting the channel
uh you know you would have to work
sometimes like 12-hour
days many days a week sometimes on
weekends like all this
um extra time was required and so there
wasn't a ton of time
to just like live do
other stuff things yeah you know um
so and that that is something that we've
been working towards and we've made so
much progress y'all oh man
like in terms of like freeing up our
life a little bit yeah
guys today earlier we got our ac
fixed a little bit and i power washed
the outside of the house
yo you don't understand how like like
taking like an
impromptu like house maintenance
task on is like we don't do that no
no we don't it's just it's not a video
it doesn't happen if it's not a video it
doesn't happen if it's not like a high
priority thing it doesn't happen i think
that like we are getting to a better
place
after cutting down a lot of things and
finding the balance and like
you know even starting new things and
exploring things and learning and
figuring out how much we want to do this
and how much we want to do that and what
the right balance of all these different
things are
it's been a journey of self-discovery
and like discovery as a business and
everything
but i feel like we're getting to the
point where like
we are starting to make room for other
things again which is fine
like normal life things but i'm excited
i'm excited to go on a date with you
me too oh my god oh my god it's so bad
i'm gonna go on a date so bad
okay right now our like closest thing to
a date is
being in the in and out drive-through
sometimes last 45 minutes
but we'll just like hang out and chit
chat
because like the the fun thing about
going on a date is like all the chit
chat that goes around it
and like you're away from your house you
can't get distracted
yeah by being in your house you know and
all the things you have to do there and
everything
so yeah just being away and not able to
do anything else
and just having those conversations that
just naturally happen there
that has been fun yeah okay
let's see what advice do you have for me
right now
this is from the uh dating edition what
advice do i have
for you right now yes
um
that's a good sign well but it also it's
kind of hard because it's like
what do you mean right now do you mean
right now in this literal
moment my advice is like take a sip of
water i've been drinking all your drinks
you know you need to hydrate like what
is uh
like in our relationship yeah but that's
like
right now is in our like this
year or like right now in this moment is
there anything that i'm not doing
well that when in their areas i could
like improve
in our relationship
or i think just i think it doesn't have
to be like a part of our relationship
yeah yeah it's just his advice um
not to put you on the spot or anything
i mean i don't i don't really know it's
like
you're pretty on top of your stuff
you know like there are some things
where like
the way we approach things is slightly
different but that doesn't mean
that one way is better than the other
i think there's one thing that some
advice that i want to give myself
for our relationship i want to
and this again goes back to time and
priority just because we've been
prioritizing our business
a lot and then we've been prioritizing
just like
spending time together but one thing
that i want to do again is like
like when i when we do the like uh nerf
gun battle
like dating thing you know like will you
date me or like these like
you can't just say that without context
okay the when i asked caitlyn if she
wanted to date me
we did it via nerf gun battle um yeah or
like the scavenger hunt or like
silly little girl like cute romantic
things
cute romantic things i want to make more
time for me to like plan and execute
stuff like that
again it'd be easier if we weren't in
the middle of a pandemic but i
i know i could do some fun creative
romantic stuff
but like you know
we we we've given ourselves like the
passes on that
just because work is such a high
priority and then after that the main
thing we want to do is just spend time
together
yeah and like honestly it's like trying
to support uh like a relationship
surprise i'll be taking
time away from us just like hanging out
watching tv together or going for a walk
or whatever yeah yeah i think that's the
thing because we used to both do a lot
more
surprises but you need that extra time
to spend
alone in order to make it happen and
spending time alone
is just not priority over spending time
together yeah that's true
i also think like you know though like
you know the the love languages or
whatever
yeah and like night gifts is not
the love language for either of us no
and even though the surprise
isn't always a gift sometimes it's like
an experience
or something yeah you know we do like
the experiences but
there's not too many i guess places we
can go right now
yeah yeah so i think like
like for both of us quality time which
is another one of the love languages
is higher up on the list and gifts which
is why i think it makes sense that like
that isn't very romantic gestures love
language or something there's
um affection like physical affection
uh acts of service which is like
i'm doing the dishes to show that i love
you yeah you know
or like i'm mowing the lawn to show that
i love you there's gifts
there's quality time i feel like there's
one more
maybe i guess we're not too good at love
languages
others yeah yeah okay long-term question
long-term relationship question
oh this is interesting oh this is
interesting at what moment did you
realize choosing me was a great idea
because we both had crushes on each
other yeah during college
during college and then like it was the
the the
relationship was like a lot more sudden
and it's interesting yeah we did very
suddenly get into a relationship very
suddenly get into a relationship
what i think that kind of smacked me in
the face like when
like like like so so you
we have a whole podcast on how we
started dating and everything but i
think that
when we started hanging out together
because like we
we were single for a while for a little
bit and
we were living like our own lives and
everything
and then when we started hanging out
again
i realized my life was just so much
better
like with you in it and we got along
so well and i don't know it just like
clicked yeah there wasn't a single
moment
yeah but like and it was also it's like
some of the moments
i think like like that like like that
like that example aren't
it's more like like
moments where we realized that
we thought the other person was the
right person for us not that we chose
correctly because
saying like what was the moment when did
you realize choosing me was a great idea
like that um insinuates
that you had the realization after you
already got together
but i think we had those realizations
before we were even dated before we were
even dating which is why this is kind of
a weird
question for us for us specifically it's
kind of like there's all these puzzle
pieces
and then we were both single and we're
hanging out and everything just fell
into place
yeah something i think because because
like we've been
we had known each other for so long so
we already knew all these
compatibility things it's like we knew
we were compatible in all these
different ways
i think one interesting thing for me and
this is going back to before we were
dating this is when i had a crush on you
junior year
and like how i
i don't remember i don't know exactly
how or like
exactly when i realized it but
i had gone through some not great
relationships
like like a series of a few not great
ones in a row
and um
like through all of those troubles i
talked i was like talking things out
with you you were like one of my
sound boards you know trying to figure
that stuff out and
of course you were in a relationship at
the time in a like a long-term
relationship yeah
um uh but i just had this
realization of like man there's a lot of
just i don't want to say
like i'm trying to choose my words
carefully
there's a lot of people out there that
are haven't fully developed
hopefully yeah or just like you know
there there's a lot of different types
of relationships that work for people
and those relationships don't work for
me
and i was finding out a lot about the
types of relationships that don't work
and like
you were such a
constant in my life and we like
communicated so well and a lot of my
issues in my relationships
went back to like not good communication
and like i wanted to try to work things
out with words and like if things
for me like if there's fundamental
like really big red flag differences
between you know like in a relationship
like we were saying you know we're kind
of long-term people if there's like a
really big red flag relationship
i think it's better to end things when
you find that out yeah
and that's what i would do and i think
like
realizing all those red flags and like a
series of relationships
like it just like the contrast
and like i you know i would always go to
you for advice and it just made me
realize that like
how well we get along together how much
on the same page were how much on the
same page we were
like and i think
one of the little moments that i
realized that was
like we were both back on campus early
you because you were like an r.a or or
um i forget that paul manager manager
and
i was there because i was working on the
school paper that semester
and it sounds so
um and uh we were both back on campus
early and there weren't that many people
and there was like the first
like pre-campus event or whatever where
i think there was like posters or
something
um and we ran into each other
uh for the first time that semester and
you kind of like picked me up and like
spun me into a hug
and like i don't know i just felt like
like very loved and special and i don't
know like
it was just like a moment of just like
oh i don't know where i like started to
like see you as
as more than just a friend and then that
combined with
all the other stuff i mentioned i like
that story
it makes me happy i love you i think
i don't remember what the question was
one of the first signs when i
when i started realizing like that i had
feelings for you i think that i actually
think back on it i do remember one of
the things where i'm like i'm confused
it's when we were watching a movie at
your friends
at our friend's house and i wanted to
sit next to you and i was very upset
that i wasn't sitting
actually and i'm like why am i feeling
so strongly about this
i remember that too because i was
feeling really upset too and it's so
funny because we were watching avatar
the last airbender
and there's an episode where oh really i
was like
i thought you were watching like tron or
something like that
um but recently we were watching avatar
the last airbender and there's an
episode where they're all watching a
play together
and i'm not going to say character names
because if you haven't watched it i
don't want to like
give stuff away but one character has
feelings for another character
but the third character like sat in
between them and he was like
can we switch seats and you know
no i want to sit there it's hard not to
like say names
yeah good story good story anyways
okay the co-workers are are
interesting but not that deeply personal
the co-workers like
and it makes sense you wouldn't go that
deeply personal with the co-workers
but um what do you think are my top
three priorities right now
um uh not burning out
um
like this is interesting because i
actually i have some thoughts on this
okay some of these can kind of be like i
don't know if they would be separate or
considered combined um because like
under not burning out i kind of include
like
not getting too overwhelmed being happy
like yeah i think that all falls into
that yeah um
i think one of your priorities
that you would want to do more of
but you're not is
better staying in touch with family and
friends um
yeah i would want to do that it's
interesting because like this is like
the the
the work one but that is that is a top
priority
maybe these co-workers know each other
well
it doesn't it didn't say work oh yeah
with my top three priorities
right now um i think the other is just
like
like in general being happy with life
and finding out like the best ways to be
to like maximize happiness i think about
that all the time
i know and i like like i i i'm like
reading a book and i like always try to
like analyze like
what is it about this book that i like
what is it about these characters that i
like what is it about this
this the way they're living their life
that i like or just like i think about
like
the best way to live life a lot and that
is like my number one biggest priority
in a way like figuring out
life yeah i think there's a big part of
the other two things are like kind of
wrapped up into yeah
i think interestingly for my my top
three priorities for work right now
because that's where i kind of went with
it but i think that one thing that is a
bigger priority for me
than it is for you is to like explore
and understand the full scope of our
work as soon as possible
that's always been like a push of mind
that i've been like dragging you along
with me in a way like starting new
things and like let's do a garage stream
let's do like
you know art streams unless like so like
you know the whole
pushing the gaming podcast was together
but i was the one that pushed us to like
dude garage streams as early as possible
like you know to kind of
use some of the momentum from the
underwater stream to kind of
explore new possibilities and new
content types
even though we had done it a long time
ago is very different now yeah when we
our first couple attempts
yeah so that that's kind of been the big
priority for me because like
in a way you know knowing what we're
leaving on the table and how valuable it
is
has been a big priority for me because
that that stresses me out in a way yeah
feeling like there might be like
yeah stuff we're leaving being being
overworked stressing me out and
deadlines approaching and lots of work
and everything
stressed me out so but also it's like
knowing
that like we're spending our time
in the maybe the not mo
the most efficient mix and everything
because we haven't explored this or that
or whatever
that's always been like a big priority
for me
yeah yeah i mean i it's interesting
because like
the um i
get that feeling sometimes when it comes
to like second channel type stuff um
and they're often times the reason
why like the reason we didn't post on
the second channel for so long and we
did we have started posting
um some things there now but the reason
we didn't for so long is because
we had this conundrum of like well
you know how how do we determine what
goes on the second channel versus what
goes on the main channel because i
wanted to try
branching out into other types of videos
so like
the first time we did a bob ross video
that was really big branching out like
doing painting on a
you know maker channel yeah um
uh or like the cooking video we did
recently which oh there's uh
it's gonna be another one soon yeah um
uh
oh like the first time we did soap
making like
uh and i think it's
now now for for me like and i think that
we've talked about this some so correct
me if i'm wrong but like
part of the reason why it's hard to know
where that line is is because that line
has been growing on the main channel
and we don't want to start a series or
start making a certain type of content
on the second channel
when eventually it would fit on the
first channel exactly
so yeah so like there's some things
where it's like very easy to decide if
it
would go on the second channel or the
main channel um but then a lot of things
like cooking was originally gonna be on
the second channel and then i edited the
video we're like oh this is good maybe
we'll just put on the main
i'm so glad we did yeah i'm really glad
you did yeah um
yeah yeah that's interesting okay let's
do another dating one
oh we might need to um wrap up after
this one gosh
okay we'll do one last one okay how do
you know when i'm really smiling
because you're not a good actor
okay that's that's it for
for me it's when it like it hits your
eyes oh yeah i guess
you guys yeah like not that either of us
really like fake smile
much or anything like i think that there
are some like polite smiles that we'll
do
like if we're out and about or we're
like tired and
they're polite smiles of like saying
like hi i'm friendly yeah or that we're
like having a
sponsor call or like video call or
something yeah like
oh yeah uh-huh uh-huh yeah but it's like
when it reaches your eyes for you
yeah all right that's fine i liked this
game me too it was fun
this was really really fun the time flew
by
way faster than i thought this is like
one of the fastest
podcasts that i've experienced i know
and again it's um
theskindeep.com is a website the card
game i think it's just called like
the and yeah i'm actually kind of
excited too because we even have a
family edition and a stranger's edition
we have even more and we haven't even
scratched
the surface of this no like this is like
there's a
cool stuff yeah at least a really
interesting conversation oh
also i'm curious to get y'all's opinions
i'm
i'm guessing that i know what what
people's favorites are going to be did
you like the co-workers
the friends the dating or the long-term
couple it might be kind of hard to keep
track of what was what because we
switched around oh yeah we switched
around a lot
so if you can maybe maybe we'll
distinguish that better in the future
that was my bad probably yeah i think it
was just hard to it's kind of hard to
keep track
it was fun to have the mix though you
know the co-workers because
so much of the co-workers touches on our
relationship in a way
and that's our life so co-workers are
like life and relationship
friends honestly they could all be the
same deck i think they're all
like for us but i i i'll say the
co-workers
wasn't as like deep like one of the one
of the upcoming ones that i'm not even
gonna do
do your best impression of me dancing
yep we both have pretty goofy games yeah
we have a lot
of this is one of many
sorry for those of you guys who are just
listening you missed the epic dance
party
if only this was a more full camera than
they get then we could do even more
moves oh more moves oh yeah
are you ready for the thing of the week
what's your thing of the week
all right so the thing of the week um
has a theme
today um they're both things that we
have received in the mail
and they're both super cool could i can
you pass me the um
branding iron yes we got an epic
supervisor in space
branding iron from design the everything
and it's
so cool it's so cool designed the
everything
yeah um and found them on
instagram they also have a website yeah
so that's just really cool i'm really
excited to use this on a piece of
furniture
and it's a supervisor approved on the
side so it's like supervisor in space
and then supervisor approved finally
like legitimately i know
supervisor approved things i don't i'm
so excited it was it was very thoughtful
i thought it was neat because like they
really
understood our brand yes we're just
seeing and
uh that's that's pretty great and design
everything has like been with us on
twitch for a long time
like you know we we really appreciate it
if you're listening thank you
thank you um and if uh you're someone
else and you're watching
uh check out their work yeah on
instagram we'll have a link yeah it's
very cool
and our next thing is it's slightly
bigger
okay it's heavy this it's cool so it's
from our
friend uh sean hogan um we first
i think heard about him from jimmy jimmy
jurassic yeah well because sean
sean has a youtube channel where he um
makes music
using noises i guess would be like a
good
broad summary um and so
you know he'll have like he'll use like
the
sounds of water droplets to make a song
or like
all cat sounds to make a song yeah and
we collaborated with him for that one
uh not for cat songs for workshop songs
we did workshop sounds
oh no but didn't we uh send him oh we
did send him cats that's like something
um uh nyan cat using cat sounds oh yeah
yeah
yeah too yeah yeah we sent uh a uh
supervisor clips to sean and he made
nyan cat
from the supervisor yeah and we yeah we
did a uh a collaboration a long long
time ago where he made music
using sounds from our workshop yeah um
but yeah so sean hogan uh is the channel
name but he sent us this really cool
speaker
guys look at this the power switch
is a key it's a key how cool is that
oh here connecting it's so cool yeah so
it's a little bluetooth speaker
it's got awesome knobs it's all um the
box is all
wood it's got like finger joints along
the sides it's just so cool looking so
yeah
he made he made speakers for a while
under the name retro blue
but i think that his primary focus these
days is
his youtube channel yeah uh yeah i don't
think that he that he's
they're doing the speakers as like a
company anymore but
he just sent this to us like randomly it
was super sweet yeah
you know and we we chat with with sean a
decent amount over email we're always
keeping in touch and stuff he's one of
the first like other youtubers that we
started talking to and we both
were around the same size and we both
kind of grown at a similar pace and it's
it's been interesting like he came over
and we had yeah we went to torches and
had tacos and stuff like
back when we had you know a few dozen
thousand
subs because youtubing is confusing and
it's sometimes nice to just
hang out with someone else who doesn't
hang out with someone else who doesn't
understands all the
stuff that is hard to talk about
publicly at times
yeah yeah so thank you thank you
thank you yeah we love our we love our
gifts we thought this would be like a
fun opportunity
to shout them both out we'll have links
in the
description yeah well and make sure that
you guys are following the podcast to
catch the next
episode of evan and katelyn podcast and
we really appreciate all the reviews
that you guys have been leaving
wherever you can leave reviews i know
the podcast world is kind of confusing
at times but
i think it's just so fun that like the
evan and katelyn podcast is like
well rated and is in the charts and like
someone might stumble upon
a great prank for for people who just
like tune in and they're like
what yeah people don't know who we are
and they just find us out
in the ranks yeah that's great um like
our podcast has no
meaningful like description that comes
from the podcast it just says
evan and katelyn podcast why why
does just these two people have a
problem it's not like it's not like
they'll find it
couples therapy or it's not like like
business or like youtube insider or
something like that nothing descriptive
it's just
the two of us we're gonna keep it that
way we're gonna keep it that way
um but thanks for listening in as always
and look forward to seeing you in the
next one
bye
that was good oh someone that was fun